>> Tucker: MILLIONS OF
MALCOLM JENKINS ARE ADDICTED
TO OPIOIDS.
TENS OF THOUGH SANDS DIE
FROM THEM EVERY YEAR.
THERE IS ANOTHER ADDICTION
CRISIS GOING ON THAT GETS NO
COVERAGE AT ALL.
TENS OF MILLIONS OF MEASURES
ARE HOPELESSLY ADDICTED TO
THEIR ELECTRONIC DEVICES.
PARTICULARLY TO THEIR SMART
PHONES, ONLINE VIDEO GAMES
AND LOTS OF OTHER THINGS
THAT BIG TECH HAS GOTTEN
RICH ON.
IT'S A BIG DEAL.
DR. DAVID HILL IS CHAIR OF
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS COUNCIL ON
COMMUNICATIONS IN MEDIA.
HE SAYS THAT SMART PHONE
ADDICTION IS A CRISIS FOR
OUR SOCIETY.
DR. HILL JOINS US TONIGHT.
DOCTOR, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
WHEN YOU SAY IT'S AN
ADDICTION, WHAT SENSE DO YOU
MEAN THAT?
CLEARLY AN ADDICTION THAT
THE AVERAGE PERSON CHECKS
THEIR PHONE 70 TIMES A DAY.
IN THE CLINICAL SENSE IS IT
ADDICTIVE?
>> I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
WOULD SAY IT'S ADDICTIVE,
TUCKER.
IN FACT, THE DSM 5, THE
CURRENT MANUAL THAT
PSYCHIATRISTS USE
SPECIFICALLY CARVE OUT THAT
THERE IS NOT REALLY A
DIAGNOSIS CALLED TECH
ADDICTION.
NOW, THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
DIAGNOSES THAT THEY THINK
ARE WORTH INVESTIGATING.
AND THOSE ARE PROBLEMATIC
INTERNET USE AND INTERNET
GAMING DISORDER.
THOSE SORTS OF PROBLEMS ARE
THOUGHT TO AFFECT UP TO
MAYBE 8%.
THE NUMBERS DIFFER FROM 4%
TO ABOUT 9% OR 10% OF
AMERICAN YOUTH.
BUT, WHETHER THAT'S AN